gang that state trashy tour is in full
swing and we're coming to a city near
you round up the squad and come out and
see the boys I gotta keep this one in
flatbreads Hachi Machi gang it's a mix
of stand up and live ayg we play with
the crowd you've seen the clips it's a
good time gather the crew and let's go
shout out to the army of garbage yeah
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find it at the
group to be classy yeah they're just a
big old piece of trash I'm your hostage
Foley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're out back here at hoodies in the
new edition living high on the hog she
just stole a bunch of meat from the
grocery store okay so we're gonna be
eating good for the next couple of weeks
gang great Mike co-host is coming at you
from right next to me unamused this week
what are you gonna do but he's the CEO
of Ru garbage he's an international
businessman and even though he wasn't
laughing at my Toadies he's my best pal
in the whole wide world give it up for
KJ Kevin James Ryan what up gang thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
your rate of you subscribe on iTunes
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are true cooking gang
then obviously the greatest website of
all time
www.patreon.com gang check it out it's a
goddamn party over there yeah we love
you gang and having a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire the
old magic man he likes grinding rails
and humping legs giving up for T-Bone
scruffins it's Toby McMullen everybody
what up boys we got the most Jack dude
in comedy in here man hasn't touched a
real ass hasn't touched a grain of sugar
in months looking straight sucked out in
the ocean
he looks a real giant boys I really
appreciate it he's scarier than usual is
that garbage or is that classy to be in
shape you know you look more Puerto
Rican to be honest with you well that's
a very that is a that is a very
interesting
thought right like what is is it more
trashy to be in shape because I feel
like I'm like prison I don't work a
prisoner it depends how you get in
trouble this is your race if you're
white and you get in shape it's classy
if you're Brown and you get in shape
it's trashy no I think you you look
classier you got a nice color you got a
nice tan you're [__] tightened up you
look fantastic I'm feeling pretty good
it's been a good summer doggies
everything looks clean gang we couldn't
be more excited to have our incredibly
and I mean incredibly special guest back
with us again today we absolutely love
them you know them you love them he's
got a brand new special right now on his
YouTube page 30 minutes with Louis J
Gomez give it up for the real ass dude
Lewis Jay there he is
fighting shape ljg in the building yeah
thank you boys thanks for having me back
I appreciate it love are you garbage
love you guys you guys are turn coats
your Traders you have no spines but
we're still friends if that is not a
testament to how [__] gooded guys you
are the fact that you guys really you
really hung me out to dry embarrass me
in front of my family my friends my
co-workers and really you know just I
don't Harbor any resentment I don't
think about it every time your name
comes up
I can tell you we're a little salty when
you walked in when you were looking
around Toadies there wasn't oh man
there's this all right yeah I wish your
producer would hang himself with one of
these wires
that's [__] Christ dude by the way
that's what the producers do so you guys
know this [__] face I'm telling you
right now he's he it's all smoke and
mirrors half of these wires aren't
connected to anything he wants you guys
to know that he's needed so I I need
them to there's 17 cameras here most
people do this with an iPhone sure okay
we all know what you're doing over there
yeah it's making himself seem important
yeah working hard baby this is what we
we figured out years ago that podcasting
is like oh you need a camera or two you
need a couple microphones that's all you
need and we kind of laughed a few years
ago but you go into like um you ever do
like those Fox News shows like red eye I
haven't but yeah but you go in and you
go in and it kind of looks like this
you're like we don't need all this sure
and here we are again boys wait till the
drones come in it's a 20 minute mark
he says we need him I've never seen him
use the shots I caught him on GarageBand
yesterday I don't know what he's doing I
don't know what any of this [__] does
buddy congrats on the special thank you
congrats to gas digital you're producing
a bunch of [__] specials you got them
cooking yeah I'm pumping but six of us
that did them we did six half hour
specials over the course of three nights
it was uh Dave Smith first Kurt
Metzger's just came out last week mine's
out uh today officially
um and then next week is Colin turo sure
Jordan Jensen and then Rich Voss they're
all incredible comedians very different
very different perspectives just kind of
like it was really a great group and I'm
happy how they came out they were
[__] great it's awesome and I've
always said this of you while you know
you ruffle some feathers from time to
time with a lot of people you have done
more for New York Comedians and or
comedy as a whole then [__] anybody
it's I I have a pool now it's all for me
it's nothing it has nothing to do with
anything else
I know I have goals in mind and very
often in some of those goals the
peripheral benefit is that I get to work
with some of the best comedians in the
world and create amazing projects really
cool right so that's but it is
self-serving I'm not I'm not [__] out
here you know doing [__] for anybody I'm
trying to [__] get a little money in
the bank put some cash for my [__]
Sunday I I get hit by a bus he's got
some memories with his pops he gets a
little bit of cash that's it man I've
always said this you are a fantastic
father I appreciate it you do it you do
a lot you do a lot for them it's amazing
you're still renting though right still
renting what's going on what you want to
buy a place I'm a businessman
I'm buying a place you are I'm so it was
it's a timing thing right me and my
chick she just moved to the east coast
she's been touring a lot it was a weird
time as she was moving here to buy a
place sure I was looking to buy I was
looking to rent my real estate agent hit
me up with the [__] best house I
[__] it's such my house that I live
in right now is awesome and I'm renting
it right but it's got a heated salt
water pool it's an amazing kitchen like
[__] marble you know marble white
kitchen like it's a really beautiful
home your first move was was out there
out to Jersey yeah rented a house you
did a lot to it you put in the gym you
put all that stuff yeah yeah I mean I
people people say that they're like Call
of Duty [__] ball gym equipment I
have that gym equipment so it's you know
it's I I knocked out a couple of walls
what's the big deal the so I I've been
kind of bouncing around to different
places and each place I move into I
realize what I don't like about it I
realize what I want and now I've
officially said I'm never renting again
this well this is up next summer nice
um it's a [__] great house I really
love it and also now I know what I want
now I know I need a pool I need a pool
oh gotcha well if you live in your
[__] life yeah honestly I didn't know
I didn't think I'd ever give a [__]
about having a pool but now that my son
the the [__] joy that him and his
friends have sure every time they get in
that [__] pool and it's it's just
great dude I you know so hey this guy is
that place is that place Gomez Central
like does the family come over to to
yeah oh yeah yeah my sister there's not
a nicer house than that Gomez
I don't know the rest of them but I'm
going out on a limb saying that's the
creme de look the halfway house my
sister so here's the thing I [__]
it's got a keypad entrance okay so it
just breaks in all the time and steals
all my weed so I I'm trying to figure
out who are old ways I'm trying yeah I'm
trying to [__] figure out how to
change the keypad I can't figure out
that's garbage I can't figure out how to
change the keypad thing I have one in
the house I just got it and I can't
figure out how to change it either and
they're close by right the whole family
whole family's my son's mother lives
five minutes away my sister lives five
minutes away we're all right in the area
look at you it's wonderful I love you
say the pool with salt water did I hear
salt water heated whoa jacuzzi
no when you get the house probably do
you want to build or do you wanna you're
gonna buy something I'm just gonna buy
something I actually have my eyes on a
house right in the neighborhood already
I got I'm looking this guy's a [__]
mover and Shaker I'm ready look people
you know people give me [__] for for
renting like dude what do you rent still
it's like you got to know what you want
dude if I would have bought a house
three years ago like I initially
intended to I would be stuck in a house
that I hate
simple as that it's good thinking yeah
now I know what I want I know [__]
what I'm looking for the type of
backyard that I want like even now this
house that I have now I love it but I'm
like hey you know what it needs more
privacy in the backyard master bathroom
needs to be a little bit bigger and if I
would have walked into this house they
would have sold me day one if it was for
sale 100 so you you know I'm [__]
dude I've been in New York City for 20
years and just used to little tiny
apartments and then just you know I'm
not a Suburban guy dude I don't [__]
know [__] about the you are though now
now I am your day for every four years
you take to it very well but I don't
because I'm going broke because I'm just
paying people to do the things that
normal Suburban guys do sure so I have a
landscaper and a cleaning lady and a
[__] guy who comes in and cleans the
pool every week I don't do any of that
[__] dude I [__] my wife I have nothing
can you guys hire me please it's so
expensive what do you know about wires
it's [__] wild dog I'll Wrangle these
wires do that thing on the arm
remember that thing man I was so
impressed by a construction worker they
could do that with an extension cord
like real nice and then they connect it
my mind would be blown I meant you're a
good Suburban guy in a sense I remember
when you were at the old house I think
this was last year Halloween I mean you
had like you were like Tim the toolman
Taylor you had the whole place well you
know I know how to throw I know how to
throw an event yeah you go all out with
that stuff pretty good at producing
events my friends
Halloween
it was I'm gonna fight Bobby Kelly in my
backyard I had [__] Harrington and
Alex and they all came in and they were
dressing up as characters they had
costume changes like they had the wolf
man would show up and scare the kids and
he'd have to run behind the house and
change we yeah and do it nice and I
treated it like an Adventist when you go
to skank Fest every you know now this
year there's seven different performance
areas there's we added a whole other
massive stage this year it's gonna be
[__] huge
um but in the Halloween party
upstairs is one event going on in the
backyard there's another event going on
in the basement there's a spooky story
time we do all these different things in
different areas and it's scheduled like
that dude I'm telling you right now it's
a little bit Rebecca and Christine
running around it's a Halloween festival
it really is I love it yeah and you are
uh venturing into the kid does a lot of
sports
yeah just baseball or just Jiu Jitsu and
we just saw him kick some ass in a
tournament he was [__] kids up it
wasn't even close yeah no he [__] he
well you know the video you saw
I read that through gas digital
production yeah the little green screen
action he wasn't even there
no he um no he did great he ended up
winning gold in the uh the ghee so they
did Gee and they do know he ended up
losing the no gee what's no ghee it's
like shorts and like um you know um
because the whole I have my
understanding the holding the ghee is a
big tool yes like you grab gotcha so the
gear you could hold the lapel you could
hold the sleeves any part of the gear
you can grab onto you could twist so
there's a lot you have a lot more
control of their body with no gate it's
literally just hooking and pushing and
um so it's just a different style of
grappling so we got creamed in the in
the nogi but he won Gold in the ghee
it's awesome sick and it was and he's
into it he likes it he really likes it
and it's like look dude I'm walking
around school go and put a jacket
here put this Blazer on it look at your
dad's room meet me in the parking lot
yeah dude I mean well because look it
depends like if you're dealing with a
person in a jacket if you have geek
grappling you can [__] sure if you're
wearing a [__] collared shirt I will
choke you unconscious with your own
shirt in four seconds you're [__]
people up at weddings you're not even
know what's happening doggy any blue
collar type event that's happening it's
[__] gonna happen
um but yeah like um no he he was not
like an aggressive kid at all he's like
a sweet kid he doesn't like dogs you see
it in his eyes he said very nice not
mean at all and he was gonna do a
tournament and we were like you know I'm
back in the back of my mind I'm going
like he's probably gonna [__] get his
ass is this his first this was his first
tournament he's been doing Jiu Jitsu for
about three years well you guys go to
like a workout place and we yeah we go
to a place called performance Jiu Jitsu
in Fair Lawn New Jersey which is a great
little
um Gracie lineage Jiu Jitsu Academy and
I was going there for a while before I
had my knee issues um but he goes there
and he's just a really sweet kid he's
not like aggressive he's not like a mean
kid at all so in class very often he
just he's not like dominating kids in
class he's just sort of like goes with
emotions he's drilling he has fun
they're his friends and you know we
worked on so many little things it was
what was really rewarding was
well boring people with details about
Jiu Jitsu like he had issues with
getting caught in people's guard and we
really worked on side control we really
worked on you know creating pressure and
having heavy hips we really worked on
him being more aggressive and being you
know acting first on the takedowns we
worked on his triangle defense where he
was getting caught on triangles over and
over again and all of this he's a good
dad right there man you're putting time
in and yeah me personally I mean we have
Matt's down in the basement obviously we
put so much into it watching videos on
YouTube and to go and watch him do the
tournament and to apply those things in
real time and get moments and escape the
triangle twice yeah it didn't get caught
in people's guards he was passing he was
going gaming points by passing side
control amount it was so cool to watch
and it was so amazing to because it
could have went the other way dude if he
got his ass kicked it could have been a
moment where he goes ah the work doesn't
matter sure putting in that effort
doesn't matter addressing those holes in
my game doesn't matter right like maybe
I'll just you know maybe maybe this
isn't for me but now he sees it but not
even necessarily the Jiu Jitsu is not a
forum but maybe competing isn't for him
maybe maybe setting a goal like that
isn't for him yeah it's a life lesson
yeah it really is a life lesson I'm glad
that the kids that they put him against
were [__] [__] because
if he would have went against a kid that
he got in nogi oh dude we'd have a
different kid on our hands right now it
was sort of the luck of the drum it's a
different weight class and like he ended
up just getting put against kids and he
had more control with the game he was he
was that's good he did such a good job
and it was just a great sort of like
moment there's these moments in like
like as a father for me it was literally
my favorite moment as a dad but it was
the it was it was him being born it was
slightly below this one gotcha dude my
[__] jizz went out and destroyed
another man's jizz damn it two other
men's jizz that's uh it's a very
romantic way
did my com dominated that day well
that's why I was asking you about this
yeah how were you at this what you
seemed calm cool and relaxed on the
video you're just kind of yelling out
instructions you know but as he
continues to play more Sports you're out
there in the suburbs like I said your
nice Suburban guy Lewis what's this
gonna be like because you got anger on
the baseball field and in turn
number one yes you heard me yelling
instructions that was
deeply against the rules of the njbjf
I'm
sure
the moment like you didn't see it
because I didn't post it but like the
first minute of the match the camera's
like down here because I'm like ah so
you are that Dad I'm losing my mind and
I'm guessing there's the problem you're
that Dad that could [__] somebody up not
really because now I'm at a jiu jitsu
tournament and all of these dads have to
beat their weight that makes sense I'm a
blue belt it's you Jitsu these guys are
[__] bad asses and I'm calling their
kids weak and I'm [__] are you I
think I said at one point
James is dominating so I had to I had
clearly had to let him know I had to let
him know that he was dominating I was
like domination like a jerk and this
other kid looked up when I said it I was
like oh boy yeah I'm talking to you
[__]
man if he switches over to soccer you're
gonna be a problem well no so he played
baseball I actually have a video
um it went like semi-viral it got almost
like I think a million still screaming
dominate him me getting arrested at
halftime a million views or so on uh
YouTube
um
and it was there was another dad talking
[__] about the other kids like we were
at his baseball and the other dad was
just like
I don't know what the [__] it was Kid
the baby's kid was the pitcher and
everything that was going up he was just
doing the swing you know like that type
of thing that's a pretty good bit
heckling the kids yeah that's crazy and
I was just like dude if my kid goes up
there and he [__] heckles my kid and
I I took the video of it being like if
this guy and then I cut to like um just
like a new story of a car plowing onto a
Little League field
be like kids and coaches scrambling
everywhere
um but yeah I mean I'm like yeah dude at
a baseball field I'll fight anybody sure
had a Jitsu tournament I'm like James
you know what this this is martial arts
we need to have some respect take it
died this kid's dead and a baseball
field I'll wait for you in the car let's
[__] go yeah did the kid did the guy
say anything when James was up there no
he was over I don't know if he's trying
to be funny or what it was but yeah
and then I remember yeah one of the
other dads or the other coach because
they were coaching the two kids the
first kid that my son
dominated
um did they say anything to you after
the tournament like hey you gotta knock
that [__] no no they were cool they were
it was it was they were pretty laid back
about everything you know okay um but
the other coach was coaching his guy and
he said about James he was like he's
slow he called my son slow and I was
like I was like you haven't even heard
him talk how do you know he reads at a
seventh grade level
no uh yeah but he said that and I'm like
I was like all right let me [__]
chill let me not and then James just
truly just [__] smoked this case
really smoked I mean and for him to get
gold like I never had there was never a
moment where I got the trophy
won the game I like I just never
I just never excelled at any sports or
really anything that you had to sort of
set goals at and like it wasn't until I
became like a salesperson I got into
sales
I sort of really giving a [__] about
money that I started to understand what
setting goals was and how important it
was
um but like that lesson was so you know
so important for him at such a young age
and to he's had a little fight he's got
a gold medal I mean it's like and it's
legit it's [__] awesome dude that's
where's that metal in my [__] right
now
I keep it inside of me are you hanging
them up at the house uh yeah so he's got
a little plaque thing where it has his
belts that he goes through and then we
hang it on that that's awesome that's
awesome it's the [__] best shout out
to Lewis Jacob man you're doing it right
one of the coolest things I've ever
heard uh Kip this is liquid IV oh baby
they're my doctor that's my primary care
physician is liquid IV man thank God for
liquid IV gang you're not miserable
you're just a hydrated do yourself a
favor get a liquid IV and get some
hydration yeah you know what I'm saying
with just one stick mixed with water
you'll get to three times the
electrolytes of leading sports drinks
and hydration you need two times faster
they were drinking regular water alone I
know I I mean a lot of people use it
when they're in the gym I use it after a
long Bender it gets if I get home at
night and I remember I I make one glug
Crush that couple of gloggers crush that
thing and I'm back and actually wake up
I wake up feeling like an Olympian you
got a late summer early fall nasty cold
that you can't shake and click what I
think that's what I'm doing uh it's got
five essential vitamins your body needs
to thrive B3 B5 B6 B12 vitamins they
should be calling a bingo they got on MB
let's go uh there's so many reasons life
uh to be in life to be depressed don't
let dehydration be one of them real
people real flavor real hydrating grab
your liquid IV and bulk Nationwide to
Costco or you can get 20 off when you go
to liquid.com and use the code garbage
do that check out that's 20 off anything
when you shop better hydration today
using promo code garbage at liquid
iv.com do it gang cue ball let's talk
about sheath baby I'm not even lying I
got them on right now hit the wiener cam
best in the business sheath underwear
gang if you want underwear that's gonna
make your dick look great and feel
amazing you got to check out sheath
underwear here's how it works there's
one pouch for your dick one pouch for
your balls okay put your hand in there
as you want to created by a US Army
Sergeant Robert Patton sheath was made
to withstand the heat of the Iraqi
desert so you know what it's going to be
cool it's going to be cool yeah uh my
dick looks great and it feels amazing in
this thing that's their copy my dick
looks all right and feels okay I'll back
them up yours will too stock if you got
a good piece I'm sure it looks great I
got a okay one it still looks okay but
she shows it off my wife likes them
there you go uh go to
sheathunderwear.com and use a code
garbage you get 20 off your first order
plus she's underwear 100 money back
guarantee there you go if you don't like
it send them back they got you she's uh
that's sheath sheathunderwear that got
[__] wieners on a brain that's
sheathunderwear.com promo code garbage
get sheath underwear support the show
support your balls do it all gang we
love yous and this it's obviously back
to school we talked about it a little
bit with this with Joe this but he said
after this you're going you're taking
you're taking them back to school
shopping yeah yeah where are you where
where what stores do you hit Publix does
he get to choose public school he can
wear what he wants is there a budget
public school you can wear what he wants
um Jersey's got like a great school
system great school it's been a really
really good school
um this is the first year that he's
gonna really pick out his own clothes
yeah okay he's going to middle school
this middle school so we're going to the
sixth Fifth Fifth so they do Middle
School fifth sixth seventh eighth grade
school district and uh yeah I mean we'll
go
yeah like honestly that's what I told
his mom because he worked very often he
wears like sweatpants and [__] like the
little kids wear I'm like I was like we
can afford they're stylish though
they're sweating no are they like
Russell he needs to I said we could
afford to buy him like nice clothes he's
a good looking kid he's a Charming kid I
was like let's go and get him like nice
clothes just get laid over here I'm just
saying doggy you don't want to go too
nice
to look like a [__] you want to have
just nice [__] though he should look a
little crisp he should name brand stuff
yeah exactly you know is he into any of
that stuff at all does he ever say to
you I want these Jordans or I want this
or I want that he look I got him a
couple pair of Jordans um and he he
really likes him he likes dressing nice
he's so little kid man we just told him
about Santa Claus just two nights ago
really we just told him about Santa
Claus it's crazy dropped on in September
doggy we dropped it on him I mean he was
going to middle school he just won a
tournament he just dominated other men's
come
this was the this was the summer of
growth you know we just did a another
vacation or we do our father son trip
every year we I took him to Costa Rica
we you know he surfed he had a jet ski
by himself which was extremely
irresponsible on my end yeah you
shouldn't be driving a jet ski and also
believe Santa Clauses
he was not a rocket [__] looking at
chicks on the beach and he believes in
Santa Claus is crazy dude we knocked it
out we got him a tattoo we got him a
hooker told him about Santa Claus
how to use a fentanyl testing strip
and here we go let them know about the
Easter Bunny how did he take Santa Claus
he had no idea he thought he thought
Santa was real wow this kid thought the
[__] Tooth Fairy was real we told him
about Santa Claus and then I was like
you also know the Tooth Fairy then right
he goes no yeah
I told you he's slow the kid the guy
knew
he believes in the [__] tooth fairy
put a dollar under his head
does he have any baby teeth still or is
he done he's got a couple baby teeth are
you still gonna break him off what do
you mean give him you're still gonna get
cash he actually lost a tooth in Costa
Rica and then he was he was like he was
like and then he lost a tooth like he
lost it and then lost it so then he was
like oh the Tooth Fairy I want to see if
she'd come to Costa Rica and I was like
[__]
I'm trying
I had to like it was it was beginning to
be too much and me and his mom for like
months we were like you know like who's
gonna do it how are we gonna do it and
then finally I was I was supposed to do
it two nights ago I was like Tuesday
night I'm doing it and she hit me up on
Monday she's like I'm just going to do
it don't worry and she sat him down she
was like we got to tell you something
and then he called me right away he's
like wow dad you're like she's lying I
just told you that why was she what
she's evil don't listen I told you she's
a lying [__]
um no but he took it really well I'm
sitting with him right now what's she
talking about the story was you know we
just we we you know we told him that you
know which is true Santa Claus was it
was based off a real person who did he
was very generous and was like we keep
his Spirit Alive now and this is a
tradition that we have and you get to
give this to your kids and your little
cousin you get to you know share it with
her and then he got into that idea you
know but it is a moment where you're
watching the magic sure disappear from
your child is that we don't we're not
religious we don't believe in [__] we
don't teach him about religion like he
has a certain sense of spirituality
because his mom's a woman and believes
in crystals and horseshit like that so
you know he's like he's like I believe
in a power in the sky and a [__]
energy or some sugar yeah it's all
[__] it's all horses none of it's
real magic doesn't exist but it when
it's the last thing that he really like
believed in where it was like like
everything else is reality now you know
and like you know he doesn't believe
superheroes are real like he believed
but he did believe Santa Claus it'd be
funny to see if like that's what that's
what turns them like now it becomes like
an absolute machine yeah and the
tournament yeah all innocence is gone
yeah all innocence is gone I mean I hope
so I hope Santa Claus tattooed on his
knuckles
yeah back to the close yeah yes show
shopping are you gonna hit any store
specifically where's the first place
you're going Garden State Plaza Mall
okay what's there do you go to like a
Macy's or do you go to like Burlington
Locker no I think we'll go around the
mall we'll go to some different stores
you know like uh what are the kids like
I don't know I'm not stylish so like
what did I do I went to like once I was
in high school yours was probably way
different than your sons no my mom would
give me like three to four hundred
dollars whoa that's [__] really good
that was like that but that was it for
like you know my clothes for the year
yeah and then a couple hundred dollars
on Christmas gifts and that's what my
mom liked she did contribute there until
I was maybe in like the 10th grade then
it then I started having to work for
myself right yeah
um but I would go to like Aeropostale
she would give you cash and go by
yourself once I was a little bit older
because Patty would never do that me and
my friends would do me and my friends
would go by ourselves and go shopping
for like our own clothes I would have
blown that money on yeah anything I got
any cash it would be okay just say cake
he's like I would have blown my account
uh yeah Chinese food with a bunch of
songs
[Laughter]
just but it's not even like good food it
would just be like you know like shitty
like 400 worth of sparrow Pizza potato
chips and [__] you're at the food
court yeah do you remember how much you
can get when we were kids for like a
dollar you get like two bags of potato
chips a crocodile and a [__] quarter
water let's go a couple crocodile
crocodile was a Twinkie that was dunked
in chocolate and they were 25 cents up
until I was about eight or nine and then
they [__] this was the craziest thing
I'd ever dealt with in my entire life
they raised the price to 30 cents
bastards it was crazy like no nothing
else cost 30 cents they felt like when
you're a kid it's based off of a dolly
you operate in the denominations yeah a
simple dollar goddamn Clinton's yep
yeah so um but for him we're going to
the Garden State Plaza Mall you know
we'll do like a Foot Locker or a Nike
store a couple of sneaks couple of pairs
of jeans a couple nice pair of jeans
some cool stylus t-shirts I've been sure
he's I'm gonna have him pick it out I'm
gonna see what he wants to get does he
have to get anything uh like equipment
wise like does he got to get a laptop or
any [__] like that we have to buy it
from the school
specifically they have a very specific
laptop that he has to have and how do
you do with parent teacher and stuff
like that
um chill with that stuff yeah I'm great
with it we're going tonight we're doing
a uh arm wrestles right when he gets
there headbutt hey Mr Thompson nice tits
honk honk let's go I'm the real ass dude
maybe you heard of me does anybody in
your world know you
like in your kids world yeah you bump
into like anything like do you like I
can assume that janitor or somebody's a
big fan
yeah the uh it's like Derek Jeter
walking by the problem is all my fans
aren't allowed within a thousand yards
yeah it's a weird thing I I I they're
waiting up on the park as long as you're
driving no no yeah so his baseball coach
her brother was a big fan of mine okay
so I ended up just walking around the
field one day and they were like oh [__]
this little shade Gomez so like then
like yeah like um yeah and he has a
female baseball coach yes cool really
yeah well one of the coaches check so
yeah so yeah but I mean yeah I get
recognized in front of him
here and there you know I try to keep it
separate because the type of Comedy that
I do it's like problematic no
I thought you were into politics but I
just don't well they act like I am like
it shouldn't be problematic because they
are just dumb dick jokes right sure
um like I understand why Dave Smith is
problematic he has dangerous ideas I'm
just telling jokes up here okay
um but it's like I get concerned that
one day that will cause a problem for
him that's you know that a parent is
gonna be like oh well it's some [__]
libtard parents gonna be like oh well he
does [__] up comedy a little read
something and then that will cause an
issue for him because his dad does you
know you know a certain type of Comedy
so that's something that I think about
you know pretty [__] regularly but it
seems like he would handle that well
though it seems like he would handle it
well and to be honest with you I've only
received like positivity in the real
world I've never dealt with a single
person being like oh [__] that guy he's
that type of comedian anytime people
either find out that I'm a comedian or
they recognize me from anything it is a
hundred percent positivity it's a he's
like oh that's really cool you're a
comic when you're when you meet parents
at a parent-teacher conference night
that recognize you which has happened a
few times they're like oh dude you're a
comic they don't they're no 99 of the
people don't live in the world where
they're reading the politics of comedy
and [__] these dumb things it's not
real like I'm just a comic if you Google
my name you gotta go pretty deep into
Google to find an article that says I'm
like a Nazi comedian but they exist
they're out there
let me ask you this since you are in
Celebrity Status over there what if the
baseball coaches were like hey would you
want to give the speech before the game
or anything like that are you looking
forward to anything like that as his uh
athletic career dude I'm Progressive no
because I need in order to be good
at anything I gotta be really
comfortable I have like my own like
insecurities and my own ADHD and my own
I'm on the Spectrum in my own ways right
so when I'm not comfortable I will I'm
really bad at performing so I was asked
to be Gary veter's best man at his
wedding
I've heard this story I gave a 17-minute
speech without a single laugh I mean I'm
talking about just brutal like just
talking about harderness to be a
comedian being in the trenches meanwhile
he's marrying some [__] Rich [__]
doctors in the room yeah like hires
people who are like you talking about
how hard it is there's like a brain
surgery it was wild the whole thing but
it's like and then I'm like I start to
sweat and I'm [__] getting like it's
really just not my um I mean I I would
you know maybe tell a [__] couple
jokes but like
it's a scary thing dude I gotta be
comfortable yeah stand up and podcasting
I'm comfortable with if and if I have to
do some [__] where I'm not comfortable I
imagine that I'm sitting in front of a
podcast mic I imagine that I'm standing
on stage doing stand up and I that's how
I get myself mentally out of it would
you coach
um
no because I'm just not good enough okay
I mean I coach him a little bit in Jiu
Jitsu because I I know I know a certain
amount but I also know enough to know
that I don't know enough to actually
make him good at Jiu Jitsu so he's in a
good school he's got great coaches you
know that that's a part of it but I like
knowing part of the reason why I like
going to Jujitsu was because I liked
learning it with him like very often
dude I go to a class at let's see he
goes to a class at 4 30 right and I go
to class at six the coach is the same
lesson for the kids and the adults that
day right unless you're working on just
guard passing right and it's he's going
through the same motions the same
movements so it's a the bond and being
able to like sort of do that together
was really really cool and I hope I can
go back one day my knees are just [__]
and I um
yeah it's just [__] hard I've been
boxing a lot I'm unboxing
um I can announce it now we have a brand
new event brand new event brand new
Carnival Carnival of combat Carnival of
combat and you're fighting Mr Tim
butterley Tim butterley great comedian
from Philadelphia start tuning you up
right now
let's go my money's on butterly even
though I love you
even [__] hit him dude
I love him he's awesome
a lot of similarities between you guys
this is The Showdown of the rad dads
yeah two great things so the the
stipulation is in the fight it is the
who's your daddy match the winner is
going to legally adopt the loser so
that's the stipulation in this fight I
mean three three minute rounds me and
Jason Ellis are producing this new event
probably two or three times a year it's
gonna be November 4th in um St
Petersburg Florida there's a bunch of
other Fighters that are gonna be honored
as well a bunch of fun fights like the
pinata boxing and the blindfold the
boxing musical chairs it's the evolution
of of Ellis Mania but you can take it
September 12th at 12 p.m Eastern at
carnivalofcombat.com I mean last year
it's gang Fest that was one of the
coolest one of the highest the funnest
parts of it yeah and we're still doing
the fights at skank Fest they we were
gonna do these boxing matches this gang
Fest but we were dealing with an
athletic commission and the amount of
red tape that they started putting in
our way in order to do a fun silly event
it wasn't gonna be as fun so now we're
doing Alice Mania style stuff we're not
doing boxing we're doing like
blindfolded karate and arm wrestling and
ass slap fights and sock fighting and a
bunch of silly stupid [__] that we've
done in Dallas Mania before
um but the boxing the amateur boxing
we're moving over to this other event
and this is gonna be a whole other event
which I think people are gonna [__] in
Florida dude
the heat in St Pete baby boy let's go
like that oh team rattlesnake let's go
this guy is a marketing genius I know I
love the idea of you in front of a real
athletic commission be like no no they
want to get tased
anybody can box blindfold these [__]
it was an uphill battle to say the least
they said drug testing and no crossbows
we were out they're like drug testing
I'm like yeah we're all on drugs sir
what do you know about fighting you're
wearing a suit jacket right now I can
strangle you
[__] idiot you're on the commission I
don't even have a shirt on try to grab
me you're wearing a tie
it's funny right before you told us
about this I was gonna say is Louis J
Gomez becoming no more classy
I think he just started a fight club in
Florida that's true but it's not a
classy move put it put a pin in there
but take it
in advance there's a goddamn show me
there's a website I'll give you that
listen a lot of people do alligator
fights all right
but I'm just saying man you're really
you I mean he's becoming more mature
okay he's obviously he's he's more
mature than both of us combined
obviously he's good at me he's a he's a
business owner a a good father uh you
know but
I don't know that you can I don't know
that you could
I think I'm always going to be me I
don't think I'll ever not be there's
like a moment like I was just you're
sharp you do great with the vacations
you're buying the house you got the kid
all squared away I was somewhere pretty
good with the ladies Houston me and my
girl were in Houston
and I see the pictures you guys are on
you're gallivanting you're going a nice
restaurant you're doing it classy yeah
yeah your new money I am but that's
exactly what it is I'm new money and so
I did this was a move this was this this
is actually on the surface would seem
like a garbage move but I feel like is a
classy let's get in there check this out
okay
me and my son you know I I he has
expensive taste now at this point right
so his favorite restaurant you ask him
right now he'll tell you it's the
Capital Grille love me some capital I
respect that the Capital Grille is like
you know it's a chain but it's you know
it's really gonna get it's really good I
love the capital corporate Steakhouse
yes awesome Steakhouse always catch one
in a nice Mall something like that
you're always gonna find it in a nice if
you're at a decent place you'll find it
it's always going to be a good time
you're not really experimenting too much
good levels of quality T-Bone was just
that one
it's the greatest it's great I love the
capital and they're expensive it is as
expensive as a good Steakhouse what's he
getting there though does he have a
taste for a nice day so we when we order
we yeah he does he's okay for everything
so he'll eat anything uh we I always do
like four or five appetizers for the
table we always try a little bit of
everything we've gotten to the point now
where we'll just split uh you know a
stake at the end using our house
because we have so many episodes
or something no usually I get the
um
uh baseball rib eyes tomahawks the rib
eye the ribeye okay usually we get a
ribeye a little marbling flavorful how
he's getting that cooked medium rare
medium depending will he do medium rare
yeah
it's tuna tartar he's raw he's a bit
darker he's a [__] you heard that
coach
that's terrible
you're the only guy I would make that
joke of course did uh so and I was on
defense about it so
um so yeah we'll get um yeah usually
medium rare but we'll get a bunch of
appetizers lots of flavors if I'm
bringing like the family everyone's just
eating off each other's plates like
that's just communal always communal and
when you go with the fam Uncle Lewis is
picking up the check they haven't looked
at a credit card say that's what I'm
saying man a single time not once not a
single time has my family or my
girlfriend ever even even nudged toward
the the [__] bill nothing generation
we could be seeing Dr Gomez Senator
Gomez crazy so here's the thing he has
expensive taste so after his Jiu Jitsu
tournament I was like what we're gonna
go to dinner tonight he's like he's like
oh Capital girls like James I was like I
found a better place in Capital Grille
all right
give us some [__] know he doesn't
look at the prices on these things right
season's 52. what the hell what's that
yeah season's 52. sounds like you got to
deal with this guy it's off of Route
nine check it out I have to say it six
times on this podcast it's also a chain
and I it might even be owned by Capital
Grille it might be in the same like
family yeah restaurants it really might
be dude all right it's next to a Fogo de
Challenge and Eddie V's Prime Seafood
yeah that's the one in Jersey by the way
that's the one I go to that's right
there seasons is spelled with two e's
and a z at the end
one of the best [__] lamb dishes that
I've had the lamb is incredible every
time every season they change the menu
okay that's the thing but we're talking
about half the price half the price of
Capital Grille if you get a [__] uh
you add on a lobster tail for 14 bucks
at this place doggy [__] is wild but
it's really good not for nothing it's
really I mean I got a tuna tartar they
have it all crab cakes low roasted
meatballs he slow roasted too
they call them
it's slow and low baby it's only
available after 4 P.M
dude it's owned by Darden Restaurant
Group who also owns the Olive Garden
and the Capital Grille
because they're almost they're always in
the same park that's a real derp dude
that's prize
they get it in bowls
no they got like one or two steaks in
the menu but then they got like salads
it's just a much more diversity a little
more casual too and it's [__] nice
these they don't [__] know I found a
better place so now he's like he's like
this is even better than Capital this is
my new favorite place so my lesson here
is that I should have never given him
those expenses he has no idea to begin
with but is it garbage or is it classy
the fact that I've recognized that I
don't need to because I feel like the
only reason I was going to Capital
Grille was based off my own
insecurity and now I can take him to a
less nice but still decently nice
restaurant and still feel like I'm doing
nice for my family no that's 100 and
yeah I think that's I think that's
classy but you hear it's like you know a
lot of like you hear that with Like
Rappers or whoever like when the people
that don't have money then make money
they go they realize I'm like I don't
need four call it's like they you spend
it then you realize oh that's not the
answer I just saw an interview said
something like that you don't there's no
house worth 80 million dollars or
whatever there's not it's actually it's
funny you bring up 50 Cent because I
randomly was at a Hilton in the steam
room with 50 cents oh [__] and I thought
I was like I was like why is [__] 50
Cent at the same hotel as me I and then
then I sort of Justified and I went I
was like my assumption is he's probably
with 30 people he's got to get a floor
and he's got to get a floor for
everybody but I don't think he was he
was with one like business partner and
they were like talking business with
like this other dude some older white
guy that owned some liquor brand and I
just overheard them and then I started
chatting with them and his business
partner was from my hometown in Jersey
so I started shooting the ship with 50
Cent and it was just like this little
moment about a meeting of the minds
right here we go
okay let's talk about Marine Lair Oh you
mean cool guy clothes yeah real cool we
were at a brick and mortar the other day
we were places all right yep gang
we're not saying you're soft but your
clothes can be soft all right Marine
layer is a go-to brand for soft great
fitting and stylish tees in the closet
Staples that you need look good while
feeling cozy with Marine layer I think
fully just had a stroke uh they were
nice enough to send us a bunch of free
gear it's fantastic I wear it out you
know in a nice summer day when it gets
it's getting cool and out around here so
a nice little long sleeve shirt on oh
they got shirts for every occasion and
with their in-between sizes you don't
have to make the choice between medium
and large large and extra large they
take care of it if you're a little round
about like KIPP Arena over here makes
you feel nice and cozy chub chub uh I
think we can all admit the perfect tea
can be hard to find I've been searching
my whole gosh darn life look no further
than Marine layer for a limited time get
15 off with code garbage 15 at
marinelair.com that's gar that's code
garbage one five for 15 off your entire
order at marinelair.com saving your
closet one shirt at a time do it gang
yeah but it was uh it was kind of
interesting and I it was just a moment
where I I thought I was like why is he
at this Hilton it wasn't a shitty hotel
it's like a nice enough hotel for me it
was particularly nice but for him for
him it was just like whatever
um but maybe that's why maybe he's just
at a place where he's going like there's
no reason to just spend to spend and
that it's it's a new money thing and I'm
not funny I don't have money right this
is free breakfast
station at Holiday Inn yeah dude I but
honestly [__] it is and that's a
little part of me like I'm getting
I think a part of me
I would show like affection by like
buying things from your family members
or friends or girls and I would have to
like spend a lot in order to like and
I'm sort of like getting out of that
mentality now becoming more responsible
I'm just like the like anything else
it's like worn off a little bit like now
I'm not
like I'm it's not so like oh my God I go
to I can't go to a nice restaurant right
I'll give example I just took my son to
Costa Rica right and every time I go
like I always like I was like price I
always look at like the price and I'm
like all right it's the minimum price
for a hotel room that I'm gonna stay at
because I in my mind that's what is
going to be nice enough right
um and then we were looking at hotel
rooms and I always book everything
really late so I was looking at with
James and he was like I really like this
one and this place was like 190 bucks a
night it wasn't expensive at all and uh
and it looked very nice and I was
looking at another one that was like 500
bucks a night and they look comparable
but obviously the one was like a
high-end sure and they were talking in
the hotel that he liked they were
talking about how monkeys would come up
to your balcony and like you could feed
them and he's like oh I read that sounds
so cool and I was like all right cool
and I was just sort of bracing for like
ah this place gonna be a little bit
ghetto like what oh and then I got there
and it was so [__] nice dude this was
like one of the nicest hotels I've ever
stayed in it was such a cool experience
it was monkey little capuchin monkeys
and squirrel monkeys all over the
property that would just come up to you
and the kids and [__] you
we get tagged in every post of yours I
feel like you [__] believe this guy
this guy's trash sugar packets sugar he
was speeding the sugars don't wonder why
they were crawling all over you this was
from the uh the hotel staff specifically
said look if you want them to come give
him a show them a sugar packet they're
coming to your room so we had fruits we
had bananas but yeah the show the one
video was I showed him a sugar packet
and they descended by Planet of the Apes
dude give him a little Sriracha let's go
um but no it was like keeping a maca
cell so they're blowing up like the
lesson there is like I was like I don't
need to like just [__] try to spend
as much money as possible at all times
to to prove to myself that I'm worth
something sure I grew up so poor that
it's like like I have this like emotion
about money I think in a much different
way than other people do like I I my my
poverty the way that I grew up was much
I don't know anybody else who likes or
unless you're like from like like a
third world country like I I grew up
like as poor as a [__] company sure
my mom was a drug addict on welfare
didn't work like I just I didn't have
[__]
um and you know it was like um I guess I
was stunned about the 300 for clothes
yeah that was it but that but that but
that was literally
everything that I got you know and that
was just maybe that was also ghetto
mentality and she got that at that
moment that also could have been a point
of Pride for her of being like listening
like I gotta send them back from the
time I was like six to the time I was
like 11 she really tried she tried right
but she was on welfare she was you know
she ended up getting sick and getting
cancer and really just like gave up on
life
um but she tried she she was like you
know part of the Boy Scout Troop and I
was in Little League my mom the problem
was the difference between me and my mom
is if James says I don't feel like going
to Jujitsu today I don't make him go but
I'm like I was like James you're gonna
feel really good if you go yeah
you should go you're gonna you're gonna
regret not going every time you've not
wanted to go you didn't go you feel bad
right he was like yeah and you sort of
get him there and you make you get him
to make the decision if I told my mom I
didn't want to go to karate or baseball
she'd go cool and just go smoke a
cigarette in her bedroom and that was
that so there was none of that little
bit of like extra encouragement she was
just kind of a lazy parent
um but I think she tried to do right by
us and I think new school clothes where
I grew up I don't know if it's in every
Hood but where I was at on Railroad
Avenue in West Haverstraw
like all the hood kids you got new
clothes yeah like everyone had to be
tortured a new pair of sneakers on the
first day of school you had a couple new
pair of jeans you had some new clothes
your first week you're dressing your
friend you're in good threads yeah and
this every kid and every kid in my
neighborhood was [__] dirt poor but
every single kid had new nice clothes
the first week of school you know and
that was that
um and I think that's probably still the
case you just deal with like the next
week they were all stolen will you hear
people yeah everybody was wearing the
difference yet but you hear about like
people right becoming new money and Like
Rappers or people from the hood or or
baseball or you know football players or
athletes and they go and they spend
thousands of dollars on sneakers it's
like that is because it was built into
our minds as little kids like hey you
gotta have a fresh new pair of kicks
right or you're gonna be made fun of I
remember my first day of school I had a
fresh new pair of kicks like 130 for
these sneakers like it was like half the
money I had for school clothes and we
were eating a bagel I had butter on my
bagel and then I I went to go take a
bite and all the butter squeezed out the
back and landed right on right on top of
my shoe and there was the holes in the
top of the shoe so the butter was in it
and I remember this kid [__] I forget
his name but this it's a little
hilarious like black kid he goes like yo
them shoes is Butters and everybody I
mean everybody
even me I was mad I was like man this
kid's good it's [__] Snappy yeah I
love it
all right let's uh we gotta get into
some questions here obviously uh guys
when you sign up for the patreon we will
answer your garbage questions on the
road a little bit of [__] vacation
and being broke this is from James uh
are you garbage if you go on a group
vacation and you know you're gonna run
out of money halfway through the trip
to me that was every trip I had with
anybody yeah I would go away for like
four days or five days with friends with
like a hundred and twenty bucks in my
bank I would try to I would try to get
in front of it I would throw a bunch of
money the first night or two and hoping
that I got good faith to ride but
everybody's in everybody's remember I
picked up that first Tab four days ago
at the airport or whatever we I mean
yeah up until I started traveling when I
was like older in my 30s
it I mean every trip I took it was
you know you sort of budge out like 100
bucks a day day one you spend 300. yeah
I'm in trouble yeah yeah [__] all right
that got away from me we're down on the
count uh I mean I went to I went to
Vegas first I went to Vegas when I was
like 23 years old to go see chocolate
elf fight uh Rampage Jackson
ran out of money uh with two days left
lost the girl that I was with like she
just was gone even you're broken my
phone battery like died and I didn't
have a charger these will fit my phone I
was like literally in the desert like
walking in the heat with nothing you
were like 24 hours away from being
homeless it was it was gonna be like a
[__] like like a like a Vegas desert
movie like it was the beginning of like
the end it was really gonna be a problem
um I remember when we went to Amsterdam
when I was like 22.
um just didn't bring enough money the
last day we had nothing left we didn't
even say amster we stayed in Utrecht
which was like a suburb of Amsterdam we
were like oh we'll save money by saying
an hour away from Amsterdam it was
[__] crazy and uh yeah like we were
just with this kid we hated this kid we
were with so we ended up uh just
ordering room service on his credit card
for the last day like there's a bunch of
[__] oh yeah oh yeah
um but yeah no yeah none of the trips
that I had and then like if you're with
a chick there's like that scene from
Half Baked where Dave Chappelle's on the
date yeah he's like counting all the
money that he's spending where he has
like nothing that's what it feels like
the anxiety of like oh [__] the walls
are closing and I'm running out of money
brutal she's like oh I want to go do
this and you're like you're like yeah
maybe I'm not really in the mood around
jet skis today that's that would be
boring yeah yeah who wants to do that
yeah let's hang out in this free air
conditioning I went to uh New Orleans
one time for a bachelor party not that
long ago maybe like seven years ago
maybe and uh I tried getting out on the
trip I'm like I can't even afford the
plane tank like a recreational plane
ticket at that point to me was like
[__] crazy bought the cheapest plane
ticket I could get there I don't even
think I paid for the room we got an
Airbnb and dude it was [__] cockroach
infested and all of my other friends who
were like in work you know like had
professional real jobs they're like
let's just get a hotel rooms they all
went in State like the Four Seasons or
something it was me and my two other
broke ass buddies in this huge haunted
house with cockroaches oh it [__] I
remember just sitting there so [__]
pissed that's the worst yeah you're just
[__] jammed up yeah being on vacation
and have it and not be awesome it just
kind of like it just it just reaffirms
how broke you are I watch these like
Channel and I'm sure it is not a bad
life right but it's like you go on a
vacation you don't have any money and
going on vacation on a budget like
it just seems like there's a lot of like
oh I wish we could do that like yeah
you're just looking at other richer
people doing stuff I just feel like
let's just do let's just lobster tails
sure look yeah you see like you'll see a
channel they're like oh you were going
to Costa Rica on a budget it's like
we're gonna show you all the things you
can do it's like here's how you can eat
for three dollars a day it's like this
doesn't seem fun this doesn't sound like
a vacation you kids want to fight the
monkeys
yeah it's brutal yeah uh that was every
vacation yeah it was wild
you want another coffee please oh I
didn't want to I like how he does it
like using gas digital he's not okay I
just disrespect my producers and like
just tell Vinnie Vinnie hey bro I'm
kidding
right away sir I don't shine shoes no
more you had it ready
uh all right let's see here another
vacation one kind of uh this is from uh
not Nick Skinner is it garbage to leave
the hotel TV on high when you leave the
room to deter people from breaking in do
you have a protocol in a hotel room
that's a great question for you well
that's crazy nobody's breaking in your
hotel room I do it for sure I leave the
TV on at least don't let them think
someone's in there I leave it on my
apartment I all the time what I do at my
home is I set up um you remember in Home
Alone where he had all the bottles
that's a nice you got [__] Michael
Jordan that's what I do at all times and
I have strings and I have music playing
yeah I don't let anybody think that I
think there's a lot of people there not
only is someone home we're having a
party yeah dude just corn blasting yeah
well you use the safe in a hotel room
if I'm in another country yeah if I'm in
this country no so if I'm in another
country because I've had money stolen
from me in other countries Hotel
Staffing out of the bag yeah whatever I
don't even have a lot of cash and I it's
you're just broke I remember I was in
Puerto Rico saying at the paradisus
resort which was the only all-inclusive
resort in Puerto Rico at that time I
think it still is and um yeah the staff
I had we only had a couple hundred
dollars it was all inclusive so it's
like everything's paid for I used to
love it all inclusions
I got a couple hundred dollars God
forbid something happens all right just
get that that's it so we were staying at
this I was gonna run out of shrimp we're
good that's that and yeah they stole
like the money they sold the cash the
cash was gone and that's all I had so I
know they sold the cash damn and um yeah
it becomes a hole to do and then I I was
I started getting even more annoyed
because I had to go file a report and go
to this office and it's this big massive
Resort so like half my day is just on
Golf Course going back and forth like
writing [__] and like it's just it's
really annoying so yes if I'm in another
country I use the safe every every time
my watch
um what do you do with your passport
when you're abroad do you take it out
with you or you save it safe and don't
take it with you when you go around
anywhere no I take a picture of it on my
phone that's what we were just talking
about yeah we were just talking about
because I'm doing uh I'm going I'm
hitting grease oh that's right yeah we
were talking about I gave you advice you
did did he tell you the advice I gave
him why not go I said don't go where
you're going yeah why he's going to
Santorini which is me and my Me and My
Girls It's all stairs he's worried about
the stairs yeah they told me that that's
for me yeah okay it's the [__] dude I I
it's not just stairs and he said there's
another Island that is just as nice but
not as touristy and not as expensive not
expensive I think it's called Seasons
52.
it's the same people who won't Santorini
um yeah no no Santorini was like dude it
was so romantic and beautiful right it
was like really really incredible but
just so you know like it is like you're
climbing the rocky stairs every day no I
got you every day you get to the top of
the stairs everybody you're gonna
[__] jump up and down covered in
sweat here's the thing we're we're doing
uh we're doing a weight loss challenge
on the on the patreon and I gotta I
gotta make some ground up before I get
back so I'm gonna need all the walking
and all the stairs I can handle yeah the
stairs which is about three yeah
you need 500 you can handle two maybe
three it was it was one of the most
romantic places I ever was we had like
one of those little K like carved out
cave hotels like it's apparently sight
into the side of the mountain we had a
hot tub that just like literally we were
staring out into the the Caldera the big
volcano
as romantic as it gets you know I've
been using that word like such an
[__] ever since I heard I was
romantic no called
Darren yeah if you're staying in any of
them in yeah it's it's in the area where
the where the windmills are yeah we yeah
we we all stayed there that's it and
it's that
oh that's fancy that's that's my spot
right there the one on the left let's
see that you have that whole thing you
have that whole thing
click it
you got that whole Villa I got that
whole village you gotta do that
you gotta do it this guy breaking my
balls for spending money it wasn't that
bad what do you mean I use my points and
miles is that the LIE we're using okay
where do we stay it wasn't that bad and
it took two times for the for the card
to go through yeah it almost didn't
happen because Navy Federal was playing
Hardball with it it's it's really nice
you're gonna love it yeah I'm excited
you're gonna love it dude but I wasn't
suggesting some restaurants you [__]
dude the [__] the food is really
really good I'll tell you right now it's
it's really good but it's not like Italy
where in Italy I eat everything
I love Italian food I don't love
Mediterranean food I love it I got a
real problem with it you have a problem
best fish ever had in my entire life was
in uh huh was in Paris but it was it was
in Greece best fish I ever had in my
life Seasons 52.
uh all right let's do a couple more
questions here and then we can hit the
bricks this one's from Colin never have
one red this is just a good time ever
pretend a power tool was an actual real
gun always I can't not have a drill in
my hand without [__] doing the
quickest Quick Draw I actually almost
robbed a KFC with a screwdriver
okay yeah when I was the cocktail no
when I was 18. I uh I I've told a story
on skanks on these shows but if you guys
haven't heard it give me all the money
you're gonna take
the part
I swear man give me two or three hours
this place is Gonna Be A Champion we'll
just drop a couple of screws real slow
on the counter
you know what I was gonna do I was gonna
hold it in my shirt and be like yeah I
stuck them up you see uh with the blunt
end of it
um I worked at KFC at the time don't
make me use this vibrator on you so I or
I I guess I just stopped working at KFC
like a couple months before but you're
gonna Rob the store you worked at I
worked at a different one so it was the
the it was the KFC it's not an energized
but I knew I knew the process for KFC I
was supposed to try for the ticket at
the end of the night oh [__] I knew how
much money was in the bag I knew how
they went out the back it was a lock bag
and it was like three grand I was gonna
ruin my life for like three grand and um
the plan was to show up and jump out of
the bushes and be like give me you know
and because I have a disguise I had a
ski mask I remember I stole the ski mask
I went to Modell's because I was like I
can't be on camera buying excuse look
just keep asking a bag
you tell anybody about this I'll [__]
kill you
so yeah I I sold the ski mask
um and then I was gonna show up in a ski
mask and I was in the bushes I was there
like the guy came out and I just
chickened out Louis what are you doing
here here
I taught you I thought you don't work at
this store anymore I just checked it out
and I didn't do it I mean dude you're
like one or two decisions away from
being dead yeah there was a few very
very close like we had a pizzeria owner
that we worked for that was gonna pass
the burn down the pizzeria
um and he called it off last minute we
were on our way to do it
we were on our way to do it yeah one of
the kids from Redwood Avenue holy [__]
yeah yeah we were yeah we both worked at
that Pizzeria as delivery it's a high
dollar sophisticated crime now it's
white car that's oh that's white
Insurance five grand each that's all
right you still need somebody and the
whole plan was we were going to take uh
we didn't know how anything worked so
we're gonna take lighter fluid and then
spray it all over the fuse box just the
fuse box and we're gonna light the fuse
box in in our mind that was gonna
[__]
you know those wires were gonna [__]
all just like catch fire on the inside
we didn't think about it it was
literally was gonna be a little shitty
fire we were gonna get caught he was
gonna rat us out and say he had no idea
and that was gonna be the end of my life
and I think that's what was going to
happen yeah he was never he was gonna he
wasn't going down when we got caught
yeah the owner of the pizzeria no way he
was gonna be staying at the uh what took
you so long did you get the five grand
up front I didn't get anything no we
didn't do it we called it off or he
called it off the night of
um just because man wait like I was a
bouncer at the time
um and the whole idea was I was gonna my
buddy was gonna pick me up I was gonna
literally be at work I was gonna dip out
the back door so I have an alibi he's
gonna pick me up we're gonna drive to P3
which was about 15 minutes from there
and then drive back in that half hour
and hopefully like that was enough to
not [__] it was [__] Lewis why do
you smell like calzones
you come back with a slice
that's a little burp but it's still good
why are you holding fuses
ladies and gentlemen Mr Lewis Jay Gomez
brand new special out right now on his
YouTube page 30 minutes with Louis J
Gomez check it the [__] out yeah thank
you guys it's the best stuff I've ever
done I really appreciate you guys
um having me on of course just give it a
click send it over to a friend it's I
mean true [__] dirty dirty comedy
it's it's just one of the darker dirtier
ones of the whole series that we filmed
and um I think you guys will dig it if
you guys did good stand-up comedy I
think you'll love this so please go
support it and click on it and share it
with a friend we love it Kippy what do
you got for him guys we're over the road
as well uh that second show at the
Fillmore in Philly is moving so get
those tickets don't [__] snooze on
that uh third show added in Toronto get
those [__] tickets we [__] love
you all tickets are available at all you
garbage.com gang we love you see you
next week peace